[Music]
Demi Lovato who is currently on tour
posted this racy pic on Tuesday night of
her and backup dancer Danny Vitali
that's the 25 year old pop star and
Danny holding hands and touching tongues
the singer captioned the shot happy
Pride only to delete it several hours
later a few days earlier
Danny shared this photo of her in Demi
on stage embracing with the caption my 9
to 5 job better than yours
but this isn't the first time Demi has
been publicly affectionate with a female
dancer on New Year's Eve the sorry not
sorry singer was photographed kissing
another one of her backup dancers Jojo
Gomez we gonna be over there gone crazy
every night
then in April Demi passionately kissed
her opening act singer Kalani during her
tell me you love me tour the show it's
really a show it's an experience
ét caught up with Demi and Kalani in
February excuse my ringtone in middle
school before they hit the road we
actually only meant for like the first
couple songs to be sexy we wanted to
showcase all aspects of my self as an
artist showing us exercise but also
being vulnerable and open with us with
audience
[Music]
you